you
okay um great so let's get started um so
the way that I think we should do this
is you know if you have questions that
you would like to ask during the during
the talk then please just put them into
the chat and I will
you know either calling you or read out
the question and then at the end of the
talk you know we can have time for
questions and again maybe you can just
you know either raise your hand or put a
question into the chat and I'll probably
call on you at that point and you know
just encourage you to ask your question
so so let's get started so it's a
pleasure to introduce Lynn Lynn who's in
the math department at Berkeley and also
at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab you
know Lynn is a mathematician who's got
an interesting on computing recently and
has you know done some really
interesting work on well many different
things including quantum algorithms for
problems related to linear algebra and
today he's going to tell us about
quantum linear algebra with near optimal
complexities so please Lee okay thank
you very much Andrew first since this is
the last talk of this quantum sander let
me take this opportunity to thank all
the organizers for the amazing work in
the business semester and like not only
because we're going through such a
difficult time but even in the regular
time I think activities have to say they
are very well organized and I have
personally learned a lot and if I
organize all cool nice long term efforts
like in the future I mean this should be
my model though I highly doubt whether I
can do nearly as good so this is joint
work with the two fantastic students in
the math department don't and if you Tom
and the al-qaeda-linked so the papers
are here if you're interested what
they're coming to talk about some recent
works on your optimal complexity
quantumly nearest solvers there are two
accurate technique two different
techniques one is called adiabatic
quantum computing and the other is
called eigenstate theory they can
independently achieve near optimal
complexity I'm going to talk about what
it means and if time allows I'm going to
talk about some linear optimal algorithm
for finding the ground energies and some
future works so
first of all I think there is a perhaps
a widespread reason that a quantum talk
should start with a picture of hymen
even to a expert audience and still I
hope this does the drop and which is a
if we look at Fineman through a quantum
mirror and this would be a superposition
of that and quantum linear algebra is
about solving linear systems economic
problems matrix exponential v-square
problems on so forth on the quantum
computer in the past few years there
have been many interesting and the
exciting progress is along this line and
quantum linear algebra I think is a
reasonable way it was the quantum
advantage which is beyond the quantum
supremacy now and because that's related
to quantum machine learning so on so
forth so this semester I'm teaching the
math 54th Berkeley's the first class of
undergraduate students to the linear
algebra and the first class shows a s
equals 2b during this semester I told
them that I'm interested in the conbini
assistant problem and their interest
said what's the difference and say what
I said was basically you put a bar on
the left and put anger on the right all
of a sudden you have turned this out an
uninteresting problem into a in and
interesting problem voila so not exactly
because it's a indeed a quantum
algorithm has its unique features all
matters first it needs to be normalized
if we stay a is a capital and capital n
matrix B is the vector of size capital n
capital ins to to the small n then the
vector e needs to be normalized with
without loss of generality let's say
that's the spectral operator norm of a
is bounded by 1 then the solution
bacteria unlike a classical computer
just to get a more amorous x b you only
get a letter that is proportional to a
inverse B and the question and you can
multiply it by arbitrary phase and the
solution vector was the only the same
thing and there's also been a question
of how to get the information and of a
and B into the common computer this is
so-called a reading
problem it's not easy or trivial problem
at all so throughout the talk we're
going to take this or regular assumption
which means that we assume there is a
way to put a and B into the quantum
computer and for a number of type of
matrices we do know how to get or get
them in there and so we mainly measure
the so called the query complexity or
the number of Oracle's used and based on
the query complexity with some effort
you can go to the gate complexity which
obviously relies on how you implement
the query models but we won't talk about
this kind of thing most of talk so to
talk about the quantum speed-up for
solving the quantum reader system
problem we need to worry about the
condition number denoted by Kappa and
there is a target accuracy absolute and
with some proper assumptions on a for
example it is these bars these bars
means that each row and each column of a
has no more than the increased the
Oracle should cost like a poly small n
which means is a some foundation to get
some speed up the ground-breaking
athl algorithm gives you a cure that
throughout the talk till that just means
that the dependence on the parameters
appearing in the parenthesis the
immediate is some logarithm logarithmic
contribution so it's a cob a square over
epsilon and there is a podium here
already suggested there's exponential
speed-up with respect to the cost goes
over but whether we actually can obtain
exponential speed-up but the answer
could depend on your reading in the read
our models there is well known work now
by he went on and so we're still
exploring I mean for which kind of
problems we do actually get exponential
speed-up
so but in the terms of a query
complexity this is the query complexity
the dependence on Absalom obviously is
not very good Absalom this has been
significantly improves by and highest
authority soma through a technique
called a linear combination unit
has improved that to cut a square Polly
local epsilon so the accuracy there is a
exponential improvement and also if you
use a technique by the quantity signal
processing down below a neutron and
recently in a very nice paper by Andres
gain su no one weep and you can achieve
oh Kyoto cop a square lock while rap
Sasuke
so if you compare this with classical
iterative solvers and for example
without receiving the matrix is positive
definite matrix and we married error in
terms of the a non then the steepest
descent gives you here the prefactor is
n capital n which means it's expensive
and here's couple of our epsilon which
is good but there also exist methods
like a concrete gradient which takes the
copper to square root of a copper which
means quantum algorithms they drink
they're generally expected to scale
battery and by the worse in copper and
in the same et al paper there's a lower
bound showing that a quantum solver
cannot generally achieve less than or
the cascading so this kind of skimming
is ready in the best the so called the
near optimal quantum in Dessau solver
we're talking about aims at achieving
öto takapa polly lock one absolute
complexity so there is no poly log cover
here because this is a Keota so if you
remove this Keota you can put a comma
here as well
now first let me say the basic idea
behind this LCU technique and why there
is a copper square skating so let's say
a is a hermitian matrix and there is a
condition number its cover
therefore the spectrum of a is its
content in this region decay that is -
one two - color - one company verse
covers bigger than one so this is number
that's a smaller than one the union with
this interval so 18 verses generally not
a unitary operator so you do the know
you can use some other ways to
to use the unitary operator for example
you can expand it into a four-year
series then each of this is a
Hamiltonian simulation problem and it's
a linear combination of a hamiltonian
insemination therefore linear
combination of unitary this is highly
efficient in the sense that if you get n
terms here
you only need low ok and syllabus the
implementation of efficient
implementation of for example the so for
the select Oracle requires a little bit
more thought but this is the basic idea
how do you marry the cost of such an LCU
technique for solving
QSP there are 2 parts the first part is
the cost of doing the Hong Kong
assimilation and he only married that
for the longest T that you need to do
and larger the condition number the
longer the key you need so the cost of
the Hong Kong estimations Oh key lock
key or epsilon which can be interpreted
by some approximation theory to occur
the kaabah poly log epsilon so this is
just a do it once but it's not like you
just to do it once and then you're done
this is because you also need to mirror
the ANSI last and make sure that this is
correct what is the probability that you
are the success probability it is like 1
over Kappa and therefore the number of
repetitions in general is or oto takabe
square and you multiply these two
together you can't have procured Kibaki
or poly locum are absol so it's pretty
airtight argument and there's a standard
technique to improve the efficiency
because this is a standard probability
and you can use amplitude amplification
you get a school root here so this is a
OTO takabe
with your talk about multiply them
together Kappa squared so before I
proceed let me just give an overview of
the different techniques that have been
developed for saw in the qsp
the original h HL clear complex date so
Toyota
Kappa square over epsilon the LCU 2
comma square poly log warren absalons i
had talked about before
the QSP and so this is comma square law
who are absolute there's no poly log
because the QSP does not have the linear
combination part I need to remark here
that the dependence on the copper can
actually be improved especially by this
a so called a variable time amplitude
amplification method so it's with that
the capacity of the h HL can be improved
at or the copper here although the
dependents are absolutes worse and here
you have a century the new optimal
complexity but I want to say that VK is
a really complicated procedure and at
least it to me
and so the q SP and the tomorrow
knowledge we don't know yet how to well
at least not in the literature I see how
to combine that with the VTA
but another feature of the QSP is that
you only need to query the right-hand
side for the copper times there's no log
one or absolute dependence so there's an
another line of thought to solve QSP
which is about doing it at the bottom
computing which I'm going to talk about
in detail later the groundbreaking thing
is the randomization method in 2019 and
you can get by tsubasa T and the soma so
the complexity is o kiyotaka bar over
Absalom its instead they were preparing
a pure state that actually prepares a
mix the state and again you can use a
technique similar to be a repeat
interface and estimation the complexity
can be improved to near optimal but
again this repeated faced a summation is
a pretty complicated procedure and here
comes our work the first one is called
the time of optimal and the bratok
quantum computing which just achieved a
complexity and there's no need for any
amplitude amplification
even the standard amplitude
amplification and the efficient gate
based implementation relies on CD I'm
Tanya simulation and finally there's the
eigenstate filtering technique which
achieves this complexity without a poly
look and this to me is so
my personal favorite one which is
there's no need for any amplitude a
notification is a rather simple
procedure and does not really rely on
any complex subroutines such as VTA
repeated phase destination or the
time-dependent Hamiltonian simulation so
let me first introduce the idea I mean
using automatic computing assault qsp
it's a beautiful idea really the waves
together linear systems solve the
automatic problems and differential
equations together so the idea is the
following
you you have a vector B we define our
projection operator called Q P which is
identity minus the projection here if
you have a solution that's it's fine
ax equals to B you just apply QB on the
Left you'll find that Q B ax is QB B is
0
ok what does this mean so this is just a
lemma so how to use this is I form this
hermitian matrix could beat 1 over H 1
here it is a QB here it is a stabber and
QB a assume that a is less a positive
definite so I look at this back to him
xq 2 which is 0 X or writing the most
and in the form x is 0 then I multiply
each one to this executor then I have 0
times the 0 0 times X 0 AQ b times that
0 ok that's 0
QB a X is exactly 0 according to here
and in q the other one is a so it is
also 0 therefore this executor lies in
the North Face of h21 another thing is
there's another vector in the null space
of each one which is this one B let's do
it again
so 0 times AQ b QB times b QB is the
thing that projection projects out the
components would be so that's a 0 the
other one at the 0 + 0 0 so the north
space of each one is guaranteed to be 2
dimension so the problem of solving q
P becomes a value problem which is to
find oh I can I can vector of h1 this
one not this one
corresponding to the IQ mat is zero K
there any question okay so the idea of
the bathroom communication is as follows
you start from a normal eigen state
could assignment with an own simple Hong
Kong H naught and you're interested in
some a given state beside one
corresponding to a matrix H one for
example of each one we just talked about
and does it draw a line between the two
so just here it's a simple form and then
i propagate this time-dependent really
time-dependent I'm talking simulation
song that's the time-dependent
Hamiltonian major problem and our hope
is that when T becomes large enough and
when I reach T equals to 1 and the
Hamiltonian really becomes H 1 this is
this is the same as a beside one here
that I'm interested in so the gate
dependent implementation of this
procedure is not that simple you can do
time-dependent rotor if you really want
exponential speed-up you'd better be
careful
and also another way to achieve near
optimal capacity is given by Lo and weep
in 2090 so the romantic computation is a
good idea than starting from Bowen folk
in the 1920s it says that a physical
system remains in its instantaneous
eigenstate
if forgiven perturbation is acting on it
is slowly at the onion slowly enough and
there's a gap so over the pasta nearly a
century now many people have done
analysis of this along the line but the
basic idea is always at the same so I'm
interested in a projection operator
which is something around here which is
the PS and it's a gap away from the
thing that I'm not interested in and
therefore I I start from here and
hopefully I evolved slowly and I'm rich
here so that this is still within the
target subspace under the one last
question yes there's a question on the
chat which I wanted to relay so and it's
maybe on the previous slide so under
tasks is the kernel bigger if one aims
for only the pseudo-inverse
if the kernel is bigger yes I think that
he'll be okay bigger yeah for the moment
I assume that Kaba is a couple's finite
okay so so okay so the abandoned
conversation to solve the quantum venus
is the problem is the following the H
node is indeed a trivial Hamiltonian it
only involves the B has nothing to do
with a at all so H naught is 0 Q B could
be 0 you can again study it's no space
it has the P bar we talked about before
the B 0 the other one letter P and the
other one is p 0 what we want is to
start from this P Keota ok
it's a 1 0 eigen vector of H node and
other bath it will be connected to XT
Ohta and this is what we're interested
in
so as you can see there's only one eigen
vector in the null space is of interest
and the gap between this one and this
one is a zero
however the transition from here to here
you can simply see that the overlap is
always zero and therefore for the
transition to be bias or prohibitive the
different dynamics here is an example
showing how this works I just connect to
0 to 1 the condition number for this
matrix it's not particularly large but
you can see throughout the thing and it
is gapped and I'm interested in this one
which is a 0 eigen vector and and here
what I'm showing you is the
instantaneous error at every time and as
T becomes is its key is 10 there is
pretty large if T is 100 errors better
is a thousand errors even
errors even smaller and you can also
measure the fidelity and the fidelity
monotonically increases as you
it's a time so so the more
quantitatively first of all you see back
to the convergence here is not very fast
this is just a vanilla EQC there is a
more quantitative version of this which
is I mean there are many versions of
such theorems one of the I'm not only
quoting one of them by ensign ro sky and
silla and which means if you look at the
set of muhammad Antonis one parameter
family of muhammad on use and the
projector and separated by a gap then at
any time s from 0 to 1 you can have the
following error estimate which is ETA
ETA has a bunch of terms there is
basically it takes the phone the time
derivative of H some holder can be first
order or second order divided by a power
of the gap what it says if the gap is
small the error is large if the time the
Hongkong he moves too fast and there is
large okay and second is that the T
always appears here which means that
generally we expect a 1 over T
convergence it won't be very fast you
just want one extra order of accuracy
increased T by order of magnitude so if
you assume the gap is uniformly bounded
by some number less it Delta star then
the T will be the worst case bound and
this is the worst case term will be
Delta star to the minus cube divided by
epsilon so it's a pretty bad error
estimate and you don't really want to
use it now the question is what is this
down the stuff the Delta star as you
have seen before can get pretty small
and this copper is not that large and if
a color gets larger and larger this gap
will get smaller and smaller know
quantitatively you can easily get a
bound which is this Delta star s takes
of a spoon and it's going to be bound in
the by Kappa to the minus 1
so if Kappa becomes really a large gap
it becomes really small so the worst
case time complexity T is going to be
order car
cube absolutely so the key idea behind
this EQC inspired algorithm by Tsubasa
Samantha associate last year was the so
called a randomized method is to use
something called a reschedule the
dynamics yeah I'm gonna talk about the
rescheduling later but if you marry the
to norm error of the density matrix they
have developed a method to improve the
scale from here to this one which is a
pretty significant improvement
especially in terms of color or the
accuracy on absolute still 1 over
epsilon so what is this risk injury so
what he inspired us to look at this
problem it is we're interested in this
randomization methods first of all it's
not like a key of C at all if you really
look at the algorithm it's more related
to another technique I'm going to talk
about later called quantum Zeno effect
and andrew is expert on that and what
we're interested in now is to accelerate
the vanilla
aqc to make it better so whether there
is a chance to salvage the aqc and to
use it for doing the QSP so the goal is
to improve the scaling I make you see
with respect to copper and the idea is
very simple instead of putting an S here
I put a scheduling function called FX
here so the line connecting from 0 to 1
is y minus FS plus FS times h1 and the
strong time-dependent schrodinger
equation still looks like the same and
the starting point is this biota which
is the eigen state of each knot the
scattering contribution to satisfy some
simple constraints such as this bounded
by 0 & 1 but the 0 should be 0 at the
mantra p1 and if you look at the error
analysis the idea is that the error
bound always takes the form of some each
the derivative divided by the order so
what it means is that when Delta the gap
becomes small H should be slower that's
it and you can expect that there are
some cancellation and this idea
nanu has been pioneered by Roland and
the surf for the first time show that
the so called the time optimal I keep
see for the grow research because if you
compare the standard of Grover algorithm
and a QC you can find it there it's a
square root of N gap and Rowland circle
first to fix that
so what we're taking this is gathering
is not a new schedule either its develop
against Emma Skye sailor also mentioned
by a Russian and lighter in 2018 I'm P
paper and it's satisfy the following who
de the form of the OD is not that
important you can look at the picture so
this one is a straight line which means
that it has to go uniformly speed the a
QC is primate rised by a factor trap by
a parameter P he takes the value from a
1 to 2 and so roughly they're all share
the same feature which is at the
beginning when the gap is large remember
that so at the beginning the gap is
large in the end the gap is small so
what you do is when the gap is large you
go faster and when the gap is small you
go slower that's it and then through
some error analysis you can prove that
this just simply reduces the complexity
to order cover whole rap so and there's
no not even log factor when P is
troubling to be between 1 2 and if P is
indeed equal to 1/2 you get this kappa
local rap song which is the same RM
method so this one I assumed H is
positive definite for simplicity but the
similar results can be done for
indefinite and non hermitian matrices
through the standard of dilation tricks
so now we're we have solved the kaabah
problem and copper or their copper
accuracy is already near optimal due to
the complex the lower bound we want to
improve the accuracy the dependence are
absolute so there is yet a different
escaping code with about the code a QC
exp
so it's a it's a modified schedule and
this schedule has been previous a
similar version schedule was proposed by
Nancy in 1993 so the shape of the
schedule looks like this a little bit
funny
so the so in instead of instead of
saying that I mean at the beginning it
goes fast you can see both at the
beginning and at the end and the scanner
is very very slow due to this kind of
exponential minus 1 over S type of
behavior and the intuition behind is
again from the error bound of Jennsen
2007 paper because you can see there is
a some H some derivative at the
beginning some derivative out and in the
end in the middle you have a bunch of
integral and by integration by parts
type of argument you can get the super
hydrate convergence you can boost this
up and make it the reverse air enhances
to the exponential convergence and this
is following the idea that NC 93 paper
and which is based on asymptotic
expansion of the of the projection
operator so you can indeed the proof so
there is some complicated dependence but
indeed he depends near optimal with
respect to Kappa and here you have a
poly log Kappa / absolute type of
dependence here and indeed a pitch that
achieves near optimal complexity and
again similar results can be achieved
for more general matrices and this type
of a QC for solving q ASP has
implications or another technique called
Q AOE or quantum approximate
optimization algorithm the idea of a
curio is very simple you have two
matrices one skoda whatever a driver the
other is called the mixer just two names
of each node and each one so just
alternating apply these things and with
the sama beta 1 gamma mind with the to
gamma tools on so for applied to some
initial state and you can obviously see
the connection between the adiabatic
quantum computing and the queuing away
because you
totalizer if you see this gives you a
natural implementation of q aoa of those
not necessarily the best one because it
their rigorous we followed the
mathematic path the TOA
allows some hybrid quan classical
optimization so if you can do the
classical optimization well enough then
this is guaranteed to have time come
next no higher than that automatic one
computing so the optimal protocol of the
KOA and should also obtain the new
optical complexity because autobahn is
given by time optimal a QC and but there
is an important difference so recently
in gosh coughs group showed but also
other groups as well showing that q EO
is expected to follow knowledge about
the shortcut
although the understanding of such an
animatic short cut it's Rama pool I
would say at this moment let me show you
some numerical examples and this is
applied to a positive definite matrix
and although we are marrying the
fidelity and although the RM method is I
mean kappa low gamma or absolute but the
pretty constant in terms of fidelity is
actually huge and you can see that it's
an even worse than vanilla cake you see
I want to say that this is a very much
related actually to the fact that that
that they are preparing the mixed state
and therefore there is a big difference
between the error merit by the too long
and the marital fidelity and the Inc you
see one which is only one of the method
and the time is like this there's a huge
difference between these methods and a
QC one remember that is also has a one
or absent type of dependence and now if
I look at the higher fidelity
I cannot plot the vanilla occasion RM
and mode because it's on top of the roof
and we start from a QC one here and then
this systematically go down the best a
QC type method is achieved by 1.75 and a
QC exp which is the better one right
actually is the worst and that this is
because the accuracy is not high
fidelity 0.999 QA Elway has the lowest
time complexity by definition but the
organization is the least avoid painful
and if you really want to see the power
of a eq c XP needs to tune your accuracy
downtown downtown and this thing's the
indeed the scale like a poly look like
linearly and you can see that a QC esv
skills is beautifully and here is indeed
achieves exponential convergence by the
fact that kyo a which should be no worse
than any a QC this is also like a poly
log dependence respected epsilon and you
can look at the tables and i'll skip
this thing and you can do the number
measure matrices as well the behavior is
rather similar and the behavior for the
absolute part is also rather similar so
let me see
so okay so maybe let me pull this
question there's a question maybe this
is a natural point that John Chiang Lee
ok yes what if the matrix is not full
rank there any correspondence between a
QC and the studium I think that's a
great great question and important
things whether it prevents the I mean
the transition from the stuff you want
and the thing you don't want I mean the
transitions are prohibited naively
thinking I think they're not prohibited
but maybe there are techniques to make
it better
yes a good question ok thanks and your
other question
okay so let me talk about the second
part how am i doing with time its to 36
36 okay sounds like good so the next one
I'm going to talk about eigenstate
filtering which is a different technique
to achieve the near optimal complexity
here I'm using the now-famous block
encoding model i like this really a lot
so like before i haven't even talked
about how to really deal with the
reading problem at all so that's like a
black box blocking coding is not really
exactly in black box it's a like a gray
box and what it does is to what it does
is to say that you have a matrix a which
is that kind of like a pen and it's the
numb unitary i want to put it somewhere
inside the unitary matrix let's say -
and back to it what it means is that I
put this matrix a to the upper left part
of this matrix in this sense you ain't
broken cause a which can be nonunitary
so the question is it doesn't give me an
arbitrary matrix a of size n by n can we
find central you a so that a is the
Apple half the block of this you a the
so called a block including problem
clearly it is not possible if the
spectrum norm of a is too large because
this one or the singular values are one
so this gives rise to the definite the
proper definition of a block encoding
you give me an N cubed matrix if I can't
find a number alpha which is used to
scale the matrix a you can think a
divided by alpha here and epsilon which
is error it may not be possible that I
can exactly block in code to this matrix
and I may not be able to exactly encode
that with only dump in the matrix size
or just one extra cubed I'm I need m and
C naught Q base so there is a three-way
prune the generalization alpha epsilon M
so if I can find such a UA
such that by tracing out I'm not
tweeting out sorry by projecting out
this you a with respect to
this is zero to the M power and so I
write this is correct so this is times
identity here so all prettier and a
divided by alpha or multiplied by alpha
here the difference is bounded by
Epsilon then U is called alpha and
absolute block encoding of it if this
was the first time you see it's a quite
a mouthful of things but it's really
quite a natural definition for example
if M equals to 1 and you a would it
become a Keota here if a minus alpha
times a Keota is bounded by epsilon is
called alpha 1 epsilon block including
of a it's a very powerful model and the
many examples many matrices can be done
through the block encoding I can tense
the operator is pure p.m. this part so
on so forth and many of you have seen
talks about andrius in during the
semester so quantum signal processing
roughly speaking is a way to compute the
matrix functions so many tasks in linear
algebra can be done with matrix
functions and especially when it's
hermitian with this idea emeriti
composition the matrix function can be
defined like this and the quantum signal
processing is a pretty powerful general
and a low-cost tool for computing the
block encoding of FA where F is a
complex function earlier polynomial
satisfying some parity constraints the
at row constraints are technical but
they are relatively natural as well so
you can also generalize it to the
so-called quantum singular value of
transformation and the circuit is really
really simple once you have a block
encoding Quilly you may as well see you
dagger
most of the time what you're gonna do is
this in just the interlace this you and
you it a grow with some control the
phase factors and always look like this
so the so-called eigenstate the
filtering problem is one particular
matrix function and you start from a
Hamiltonian H which is hermitian lambda
is eigen value
that you're interested in which is
separated from the rest of the spectrum
by a cap Delta which is like this one so
this is the eigenvalue you're interested
in you what you want is to keep this
part and throw away the rest of the part
and you do know what it is the lower
bound of the gap so lambda is the
separated from a way there are rest of
the things by delta y or you want to
construct a spectral projection operator
which is 1 here and 0 here but this is a
discontinuous function and is a
difficult to do but since there is a gap
there is good chance that you can just a
make a smooth transition from here to
here and without losing much accuracy
this is the so-called eigenstate
filtering problem and what we did is
roughly to say if you wanna restrict it
to the polynomial type of approximation
we get the best approximation with this
number of control the unitary is and
this number of a primitive gates so the
basic idea is the following
it's an old idea that is the mean max
polynomial based on the chebyshev
polynomial so I mean if you look at the
textbooks like a user Saab you will find
that if you're I want to do the
eigenstate of or one side if I can state
the filtery the best polynomial is
achieved by the chebyshev and this one i
want to get a two sided thing I don't
want this part the one this part I want
to keep this one and and wanted to
satisfy the min/max property which means
the error should be equity this
distributed so reach the maximum error
here maximum error here and so on
Stoffel and this is the polynomial you
can improve that this is the v-max
polynomial and you can combine this
thing with the signal processing to
implement that which gives in the
previously aforementioned the complexity
result so you can use the eigenstate
filtering to accelerate any
aqc type of technique to solve the qsp
why because we have said that the idea
of a debatable quantum committee is to
convert the linear system problem to
agonized problem what you want is to
find a zero eigenvalue here and you
don't want the negative ones don't want
the positive ones you just want one here
so let's say I do a QC I just want it to
some constant accuracy that's at 0.5
okay but it's a non-trivial already done
that so I the complexity of the a QC is
something like this and I achieve a
solution with Absalom to be of other one
accuracy so this one can be thrown away
I obtained this X note with some effort
which is carbon lock Kaaba
now I apply I can state the filtering on
top of that so you already obtained a
pretty good initial initial initial
state which has a decent overlap with
the final state because this is a
requirement now I just applied this
polynomial filtering and that's it you
can prove that this achieves the near
optimal complexity which is number of or
queries to a is other deities but these
bars which can be defective kappa and
then all the rest of things are
logarithmic so this is the total query
complexity but you can you can have a
gate complexity as well so to just to
show you some numerical results that is
indeed works for if you let's say start
from a QC gas you can see that the
initial error is not infinite I mean
something and then you just increase L
and indeed you get exponential
convergence and the growth with respect
to Kaaba is indeed very close to linear
the next technique is that as I said so
there are actually two uses of
eigenstate filtering to solve QSP so in
total I'm introducing three near optimal
algorithms to solve QSP ones EQC exp the
other is the combination of eigenstates
filtering with a QC p and the third I'm
going to show you is this quantum Zeno
effect quantum Zeno effect I mean
a little bit difficult to explain and I
certainly wouldn't be able to explain
better than Andrews I wouldn't even try
that let me just to say that quantum
Zeno effect is a very close cousin to
adiabatic one computing the basic idea
is the following so you just say X bar
is your automatic path you don't know
that a priori but do you know that it is
and you go from the beginning of zero
equal to zero
to FM m is the big number and FM is
equal to 1 if you think this M is large
enough and the distance between F each
consecutive Fi and fi plus 1 it's a
small enough and keep him married on top
of that okay that's crazy thing so you
just keep doing the measurement and you
can prove that this is roughly doing a
QC you can drive the state gracefully
from the ground state here which is a 0
B to the end which is the thing that you
want so at each step you murdered the
state you project that to the individual
intermediate eigenstate of
H F and in the end you the fidelity
approaches 1 which is stuff you need in
the end as the step size decreases if
you are increasing the time complexity
of your a QC so the idea therefore of
using the combining eigenstate the
filtering and QTE to solve Kwon Minah
system problem is to replace this
environment procedure by the projection
procedure done using q SP and the
eigenstate filtering algorithm so you
can you can analyze and showing that
doing the carefully along the reschedule
the dynamics and the success probability
is Omega 1 so in principle I only need
to do repeat this with Oh 1 times this
is really the key because if you think
about qsp or linear system problem sorry
Oh L see you it's not like each
individual form is not expensive each
individual wrong is or the kappa of
OTO takapa that is the expected it's
really that you have to repeat it for
many many times that gives you the cover
square complexity and this qze and
really allows you to do it is center
with oh one times and then you're done
and this is the the key and the
complexity is like this so there are a
few I would say pretty setting features
of this approach is fully gate based
implementation all you need to do is to
prepare the intermediate homophony start
from initial state which is a zero B and
you keep doing this kind of a filtering
implemented with a QSP circuit you just
do it for a few times and in the end
it's a successful day you're done okay
so really simple relatively I would say
simple procedure to achieve the near
optimal complexity and all we need to do
is to successfully project long
carefully scheduled at the bottom path
so any question there something the Chad
oh it was a question in the chat which I
think was about the previous part of me
will save it for the end
ok sounds good yeah ok I finally on now
ok so finally let me talk about another
thing since I'm talking about Kwon Mina
had run order just quantity in a system
problem there's a fan of the ground
energy so the ground energy I mean is
very much related to the eigenstate the
filtering problem either state
sweltering it's defined in like an
eternal I mean I came after but assume
that you do know what the internal eigen
value is but he medicate you don't know
what that is for example in chemistry
you're interested in the ground state of
a complicated many body humming I just
don't know what that is so you also need
to find you that graph energy obviously
this is very difficult task because you
just defined of ground energy like like
a five will go home Tony is um a hard so
we do have a very crucial assumption
which is that you have a decent initial
state so assume that you have a
Hamiltonian H yeah
we assumed the block encoding model
called alpha M without loss of
generality we assume there's no error in
this block encoding you have some a
decent initial state prepared by unitary
core the UI and what you want is to find
the ground energy lambda 0 and the
corresponding eigen state besides 0 and
we here have two key assumptions the
first is that there is a lower bound for
the overlap the initial state and the
desired eigenstate the gap should be
decent and the second is that you do we
don't know what the ground energy is but
you know roughly where it is and you
also know roughly there's a lower lower
bound so what it means is that iousy I
don't know what this is but I roughly
know there is a it wouldn't be too far
away from a mu and it should be gapped
by Delta and also this mu is gapped from
the other it's the first excited state
by Delta so what I want to do is again
to form a step function it is 1 here and
a 0 here if you just do this that's a
formidable task but since I do know a
gap I can just smoothly do a transition
and go from 1 to 0 so the basic idea is
developer is called a binary search
sounds like a very simple idea but I'm
gonna comment on that later what you
basically do is you construct construct
a polynomial and for example like a perf
function and satisfies that from this
here it is a 1 here to 0 and in the
middle there is some transition for
example our function looks like that and
H has this alpha hem zero block
including you apply this polynomial
using QSP to the large with a large
overlap and then you can tell whether
roughly it is it is a bigger than X plus
h or smaller than X minus H but there's
a as really the problem here because if
the 0 or lambda is lambda 0 lies here
you actually don't know
whether it is at this side or that side
so that's really the problem how to
solve this you actually it's very simple
you apply to shifted polynomials they're
only different by some tunable parameter
called H what you can do is to return
the result from two independent
measurements so let's say if you get
with the higher confidence you can say
that if it is it is a it is a 1 if
there's a return to be 1 then most
likely and it is not most likely with
the high confidence it is gonna be
bigger than X minus H even though might
be wrong but you don't know whether is
here but it's come here if you marry the
0 then you don't know again don't know
this side but you do know it has to be
less than X plus h now you have narrowed
it down from a larger interval to 2x
minus H 2 X plus h and then you just do
a binary search in the middle and you
can explain a shrink down the the
interval containing the ground energy so
the idea is sound simple but is really
achieved so far the best result to our
knowledge the before this there is of
course the well-known result is by face
destination and there are a number of on
disorients features due to face
decimation our other than that the
previous no best known results are
obtained Bangka good Torah and the 0 in
2019 so they have considered the problem
of preparing a ground state with known
bound of the crown energy finally the
ground energy and I prepared the ground
state where the pound is on them so well
so there's a lot of information in this
table I want to say that we use last
number of qubits becomes amuse q SP the
the most noticeable improvement that you
can see here they achieve this
dependence is is h to the three-halves
and that is really because the use of
grover surgeons of a binary search
and we have improved that to H and hear
you again due to the grover there is a
school-age here and we have improved
that to logarithmic and also there is a
corresponding provements when you
prepare the ground state with an unknown
bond so we can also prove that this
algorithm achieves a certain lower bound
in terms of the complexity for example
if gap if the gap is large and the
initial overlap is 0 then our you cannot
use less than 1 over gamma applications
of you age to get that and our complex
is mono color similarly when the initial
overlap is large but the gap is close to
0 the number of queries cannot be less
than 1 the other will achieve that and
there is a more subtle bound when there
is more salable here so finally let me
talk about some future works and so
there are a lot of challenges
so I also talked with Android during the
semester I think we learned a lot and so
that the large-scale for first of all
large-scale fully error corrective panca
meteor probably remains at least they're
really really hard in the near future
problem not necessarily ridiculously
hard but probably really hard so we want
to think about both near term and the
long term goes for the convenient abroad
there are a number of topics that are of
interest for example efficient gate
based implementation of a q-see recently
in Andrews group has done this very
interesting work of Trotter valve for
time independent problems how do you
generalize that it's better in this
committee the type of balance to do
efficient time-dependent simulation it
seems to be interesting so quantum
signal processing has reappeared in a
number of appeared many times throughout
the table as we have seen and I think
it's really a beautiful theory and it's
a very much related to approximation
there is the su 2
and converted the problem of a quantum
computing thing to a classical computing
problem here is about how to obtain the
phase factors one efficient approach
that is what we have developed quite
recently or the optimization based
approach and but more generally these
are related to the some polynomial
approximations with a non-trivial
constraints I think there are a lot of
things to be starred in there and
another thing that we found in this
thing is the decay or the phase factors
and there's a close relation between the
decay of the phase factors and the
regularity of the function that is of
interest I think there's a lot to be
studied here as well so the
fast-forwarding a certain Hong Kong is I
think that's also very interesting
because although there's a complexity
theory lower bound it doesn't mean that
no linear systems can be accelerated
so therefore the fast forwarding and the
precondition if they really good hand
hand in hand with each other and the one
important progress recently is down
below in the weep in this interaction
picture Hong Kong is impatiently
recently there have been a lot of
interest going beyond linear algebra but
to study the OTS and pts or open quantum
systems with algorithms I think that's
rather interesting but of course there's
a there's a very important question
there which is I mean what kind of speed
up do we really expect I think so far as
far as I know we don't know the answer
and would be really good to know a
clearer picture behind that so the block
encoding model is really my recent
favorite and but there is a there's I
think the power of this model remains to
be study folks down below the block
encoding Hamiltonian simulation can be
much trickier than the closer
counterparts and the last week we want
to give a beautiful talk explaining why
this is so
but one thing recently interested in is
how do you connect this bulk encoding
type of model with the supremacy type of
circuits which I'm going to talk about a
little later and another thing is we
have so far seen the irregular type of
assumptions but in the end when we
demonstrate that
for some real applications we really
need to get rid of all the black boxes
and go to the gray or even white boxes
whether you can still get a good speed
ups I think it's an important question
and the finally thing that we were
recently working on and hopefully can
get some results a student is a what's
the proper counterpart of the dense
matrices in quantum setting I mean there
is a famous Linpack benchmark which has
been used to the benchmark the top 500
computers since 1979 and an impact for
the top 500 it the benchmark itself
started from 1979 the that the use of it
to define top 500 is starting from 1993
can we really mimic or replicate it's a
success and how how do we really get
those dense matrices and so so or a what
should be of the proper Quon will impact
benchmarks in the poster supreme sierra
so here are a few references for the
talks and finally I'd like to thank you
very much for your attention
okay yeah thanks very much then for this
this nice talk me you know thank you on
behalf of the whole audience since we
can't have you know you can you can
click the applause button if you want
but we can't have the usual sort of a
sort of applause but now I think we have
time for some questions if there are
some and I know Nikhil had a question
during the talks right under Nikhil do
you just want to just unmute and go
ahead yeah the question was about a QC
so the question is how robust is this
result to perturbing the schedule so
does it rely on some very delicate
cancellations or something like that I
know yes so so because really as you can
see the schedule is like the beginning
needs to be slow at the end needs to be
slow in the integration I mean the the
rigorous proof is always I mean more
delicate like a disc every class type of
thing but the intuitions behind is
integration by parts what do I mean is
that if you look at this yen's and bomb
and there are this integral here
you said has to be one and then you can
keep doing integration path then the
reasons the power of H I mean to the
boundaries H power you know some
derivative of one it is some power
derivative zero and they keep canceling
right so in that sense I do expect that
it is kind of delicate and in that sense
I also think why the agus need filtering
seems to be more robust so in particular
does that have any implications for the
gate complexity of implementing a QC X
because it seems hard to discretize so
that's an excellent question
and what we do so far is to quote the
low unweave and that's actually a rather
complex apprentice and if you read that
there are all sorts of stuff other
circuits compression gadgets of BBS
amplitude amplification a lot of things
there and so how difficult it is and how
robust is I think that's a really a good
future direction to do yeah thanks
thanks so I think Ike has a question and
then others hi Lynn this is like trunk
thank you very much for the beautiful
talk I enjoyed hearing all of these and
your beautiful ideas too especially with
regard to the use of the double
polynomials for binary search as you
know the quadrant Fourier transform and
Fourier transforms fast Fourier
transforms in general are binary
searches and you can show that for
example the phase estimation algorithm
is just an instance of the singular
value transform done with powers of the
black box and so one of the approaches I
was thinking of for solving this exact
same problem which I did not complete in
the same way that you have is instead of
using two polynomials like you've used I
wanted to amplitude amplify so you use a
first polynomial to figure out the
general neighborhood you're in and then
amplify that segment and do another
polynomial to divide that into you
amplify again and divide into you and so
forth another kind of binary search
and if you had the powers of doing the
Hamiltonian to some power then I might
also try to figure out when to turn that
power up and then search in the new
neighborhood when curious if you thought
about those approaches and what you
think those might compare with your
approach so thanks for the question and
I think I mean I haven't thought about
exactly along that line I think is maybe
also a promising approach to do that and
by doing another search I guess you mean
the groover type of search thing so
basic search only only binary so there's
no okay yeah so other type of
polynomials may also work with this is
only I mean we showed that one of them I
think using yeah the approximation to
the RF function and so but one thing is
this in terms of asymptotic complexity I
think for all the parameters this is
pretty much optimal but maybe there are
other methods that would also achieve
the optimal capacity for the first
question regarding the connection to
Fourier transform I think that's a
really good question we actually
discussed about it after the first like
boot camp when we were still making
person we we did do some QSP
calculations for this kind of
approximating these kind of shapes it
seems to work and if you're interested
we can definitely talk further offline
yeah I'm interested in particularly
because it touches on fast forwarding
you know if you are given more
information about the structure of
Hamiltonians then it makes it easier to
use water or another of these techniques
like you might use in QSP to do fast
forwarding both using the extra
information that you given about the
Hamiltonian and then using for example
you might be able to compute some powers
of H or make different blocks powers of
H in the blocks and then use that inside
QSP or you might be able to use QSB to
turn your Hamiltonian given your
structure information into something a
little better because you can you know
like invert the sign or something as I
end on si GN and
and so forth so I think the more of
these kinds of tools one has the better
off we will be in doing something with Q
SPE for fast forwarding yeah I think
this is very interesting thing as you
probably recognize a lot of the
challenges I directly stolen from your
talk and well but this preconditioning
thing is indeed what we're working on
right now and like to if you're
interested I'll be more than happy to
talk with you later
oh great let's talk thank you thanks
think so I think under she has a
question yeah thanks thanks for a very
nice talk and his various algorithms so
I was I was interested in the last
version of this quantum Zeno effect
based implementation and so like you
suggested that it is probably the nicest
from implementation from practical point
of view and so something that I didn't
put the understand that when you apply
this project course in the Vedic us II
do you do you still need to measure some
ancilla qubit or there is no Angela
measurement
during these zero steps oh great yeah so
indeed they need to measure the actual
documents but you can prove is that each
I mean within each of this step the
success probability is overwhelmingly
high when they multiply cut together the
success probability obviously will be
lower but in the end they're still two
multiplied together the probability is
bounded by Omigawa I mean for chaos we
always need to measure something but
yeah so each of this the success
progress is one - a little bit and that
little bit is controllable that's really
ok yeah yeah well the reason by us
because like current hardware is
actually like not really friendly
towards you know measurements that you
would do during the computation of the
circuit they tend to measure the whole
thing but okay like I guess this is like
more a long-term talk so I think this is
not a short-term period yeah sure
yeah so the short-term thing I like the
QSB better nobody like us be better I
see thank you hey are there other
questions okay well if not um let's
think Lynn again for this very nice talk
I think this was the last talk of the
the program so you know thanks to
everyone for participating to all the
speakers and yeah thanks very much to
Lynn for the talkin let's uh let's maybe
give him another round of applause
thanks hope you all enjoy the summer
yeah at home